>> Richard: YES, AND THAT IS
MAYBE WHY KYRIE DECIDED TO GO
QUICKER.
JEFF GREEN PASSING UP THE THREE.
>> Mark: ARIZA IS BACK ON
IRVING, AND NOW BAM IS SWITCHING
OFF, AND THE THREE IS UP IN THE
AIR -- AND DRAGIC WITH THE
BOARD.
20 SECONDS TO GO!
AND MIAMI CAN RUN IT DOWN.
ADEBAYO AGAINST GREEN, AND 8.0
SECONDS.
BAM, FACING UP.
GOING TO RUN IT DOWN, AND GOING
FOR IT, AND ADEBAYO FOR THE
RUN -- OH, COUNT IT!
DADE COUNTY, HOW DO YOU LIKE
BAM, MAN!
>> Richard: WHAT A SHOT!
YOU DON'T LIKE THE PULLUPS,
JIMMY BUTLER?
WHAT ABOUT NOW?
>> Mark: NOTHING SOFT ABOUT THAT
FINAL FORAY TO THE BASKET BY BAM
ADEBAYO.
HE HEARD WHAT JIMMY BUTLER SAID.
HE HEARD EVERY WORD, AND HE
FIXED IT THIS AFTERNOON.
>> Richard: YES, AND HE HOLDS
THE TEN SECONDS AND JUST TAKING
HIS TIME.
THIS IS LITERALLY PERFECT, GET
TO YOUR SHOT, AND THE BALL GOES
THROUGH, AND ZEROES ARE ON THE
CLOCK, AND DON'T GIVE BROOKLYN
ANY OPPORTUNITY, AND THIS IS
CONFIDENCE OF THIS MAN GROWING
BEFORE OUR EYES AND TAKING HIS
TIME, AND GETTING THE SHOT THAT
HE WANTS, AND LET ME TELL YOU
HAVE TO BE IN THE BUILDING, AND
TO SEE THE FANS STANDING UP AND
CHEERING, AND THIS ENVIRONMENT
IS JUST UNMATCHED.
>> Mark: I WILL TELL YOU WHAT,
WHEN YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE
FINAL ANALYSIS OF THIS, RICHARD,
WHAT BAM ADEBAYO AND THE